well welcome this is talk about
computer-based math which I'm sure we
have now been going for six years since
2010 oh and Connor Wolfram founded it so
I'm here to kind of give you the latest
and to what computer-based math is up to
be we've had a quite an exciting year
we've made some significant changes to
what we're doing and I'm here to kind of
introduce some of those things to you
today but for those of you who aren't
familiar with computer-based math CBM
was founded to push a real reset on the
school subject of math forgive me if I
say maths I am British I've put math in
here just in case you want translation
so basically so that it reflects the
real-world subject I mean a lot of us
here anyway
our math lovers we've used maths and all
different guises most of us - you know
some of us to a very high level and the
educational subject of math is not the
one that we know and love so CBM was
founded to try and instill this kind of
this kind of thinking right from right
from the very very early stages and this
really can only happen if we engendered
computational thinking computational
thinking being a process by which we can
attack problems by which we can actually
use the computer as a tool to kind of
help us reach their solutions that we
want so the last two lines is a
statement that that is fairly obvious
use computers in school as we do in the
real world we don't want to use gimmicks
we don't want to use kind of base level
educational software we want to use real
stuff that real people use and we want
to get a whole generation of people to
use it and that you know that is to
replace humans for calculating we've
known for ages that that you know that a
computer can can calculate can compute
much more than any human can minutes and
it's about time that education kind of
really hears that so why are we doing
this this is a quote from Conrad
computers have liberated railroad mass
from hand calculating to go for her
and faster than anyone could have
imagined now it's part of that
educational math stands on this
automation too basically we have all
this without at our disposal we have you
know we have a wonderful system in
Mathematica which and Wolfram language
which we we choose to use for our
materials but but compute computation in
general has kind of liberated real-world
maths and we need to do that energy
efficient so how is CBM doing this so
we're building a new high concept maths
curriculum basically assuming that
computers exist so we have computer
based computation at its heart and we're
redefining maths as the anchor subject
for computational thinking we were
trying with doing many discussions at
the moment about how computational
thinking relates to CBM but basically it
relies on on a skill set which is partly
about you know how to structure things
how to a kind of numerical quantitative
reasoning as well and math seems to be
the anchor subject in CBM form for
computational thinking now this has
applications across many fields this is
what we've found when we've been doing
building our materials is that this this
has tentacles in all subjects where it
has tentacles in geography it has
tentacles in history it really kind of
covers a whole multitude of things but
we we can kind of Center that on problem
solving and CBM is contextualized within
a math concept area so this is a nice
manipulate which is basically a
representation of what educational maths
is right now we believe that the the
four steps of our problem-solving cycle
are the definition of your question the
translation to maths or some algorithm
or code and it's an abstract an
obstruction step then you have the
computation step which is where you get
your answers it's where you you know you
swear you scribble furiously on your pen
in your pen and paper or you use a
machine to do it for you and then the
fourth one is an important one as well
which is your kind
critiquing staff it's it's an
interpretation it's a
recontextualization of what your
original problem was
now what education is doing right at the
moment is that they're paying very
little attention to those three areas
which are which are smaller and spending
a huge amount of time teaching hand
calculating techniques and learning
things by rote and without kind of a
thought to to the underlying principles
all kind of all the outcomes that
they're trying to achieve so the CBM
solution really is to kind of get a more
balanced view of things we want to kind
of augment the other three steps and we
want to be able to use computation and
use real-world tools so that all of
these other three come back into focus
now these are real skills that that the
students need and we think that the
curriculum should embody all four of
these things the way we're applying this
is in what we call the CBM solution
helix so this is not this is not a kind
of a one-time thing this is an this is
an iterative process that you can go
through this solution many many times
you're refining you're experimenting
you're defining multiple questions and
so you have this kind of helical
approach where you're going through your
various different stages of the cycle
ultimately refining and until you reach
some solution at the top and achieve
infinity but but this is this is
basically that the process on which CBM
is founded and we've done a lot of
thinking about this in the past year and
how that relates to kind of what we're
building so what's your problem I mean
the the way that we develop our
curriculum materials is that they are
problem centric we don't we don't ever
approach things from the perspective of
we've got to teach them standard
deviation right now let's think of a
contrived thing that we can put
we can teach standard deviation it's
like or what is a problem that we want
to solve we have and I'm not going to
show you because it would be
embarrassing we have a massive
spreadsheet of all kind of brainstormed
questions that we can make modules from
and some of them are like would I
survive a zombie apocalypse through to
you know how many friends do I need
friend on Facebook in order to like meet
the Queen or something like that they're
kind of you know they're kind of
problems that people really want to
solve but the ones that we've been
concentrating on enough statistics
curriculum and things like that are a my
normal we have a kind of we kind of have
a set of different things that we're
using we have ones in geometry like how
can I create a flat map of the of the
world and that kind of goes through all
kinds of different mapping tools and own
ways of abstraction there this is really
this is really crucial and this actually
is for us quite a difficult part of the
process because we have to map out a
curriculum that that covers concepts and
tools that we want to we want to expose
people to but in the context of
real-world problem solving and what's
the outcome of this we've done some
extensive work this is actually new
these are our required outcomes from
mainstream maths this is on a
computer-based math website if you have
if you have the talk I've put the
hyperlink in there but we've split these
up into 11 different outcome areas and
they're all they're all split up into
kind of outcomes that we would like the
student to be able to be capable of so
we actually tagged these in all of our
materials so that teachers can can see
these through and the critical thing
here is that some of these dimensions
are directly aligned with the
solution helix so defining the question
these are all of the outcomes that are
related to that first initial stage we
have the abstraction here which is which
is heavily in stage two and then when
you get to tools of maths and managing
computations here you're you're kind of
in the computation in the computer
answers phase of the helix and this is
really important a lot of people who are
designing outcomes especially problem
solving outcomes try and squash
everything into a process now what we're
saying is there are some there are some
dimensions here communicating and
collaborating that sit outside of the
process these are general outcomes that
you need as not just as a mathematician
or or you know or computer scientists
but these are these are skills that you
need in order to be able to collaborate
or work and then this is something that
will help cross-curricular as well so
there are some that sit outside of the
helix and some that very definitely set
in to it if you want to download the PDF
you can we we've done quite a lot of
work on this or we've hoped that the
explanations really kind of say what
what they are so given that we've been
working on a lot of things I thought it
would be appropriate to show you one of
our latest modules we have been working
with the Irish the National Irish
assessment board to do a module in
modeling and this is part of their kind
of problem-solving curriculum and as
part of this we cycling is big in
Ireland right now this its kind of a bit
of a buzz thing and we've developed this
module which is how fast could I cycle
stage seven of the AMPA that's a really
famous cycling race for those of you
that haven't seen our materials before
and that we as they're split up into a
hierarchy of chapters of activities of
modalities below
to --'tis and then review sections we
try to we try to use questions as the
framework for the materials so that the
module question how fast could I cycle
the stage but we've broken it down into
different questions water models are not
can they tell us about cycling it's an
investigation into modeling as a whole
how and then and then specifically how
do I break down my question how much
energy is wasted from rolling along
how much does their resistance slow me
down what effect will the roads gradient
have and then finally consolidating my
model here so we kind of do a
combination of exposure to things this
is our teacher view you'll see our kind
of technical manual here and these are
all features that we've put in so that
the teacher could do this in the student
version which pops out here all of these
things are suppressed we expose them to
a model we basically don't give them
anything and we say go play with it how
is my power being affected by my rolling
resistance what effect is the gradient
have getting to think about concepts
[Music]
getting them to think about concepts
before they actually try and break
things down and then we ask them
questions about you know formulating
their question the vast majority of the
first chapter is about defining their
question once they've defined some
questions we we kind of get on into the
breaking down the problem and this is a
guided learning approach there are three
facets to CBM this is very guided and
then we also have kind of a less
structured approach which is our
projects at the end which scaffold some
of the stuff but doesn't walk them
through it and then a project-based
activity is kind of the least guided so
we we encouraged them to kind of use our
image processing tools here so they're
taking actual frontal area pictures of
themselves so they can find out their
own frontal area and how effects that
they're there are resistance so and the
good thing the good thing about this
also is that
we bring the the problem-solving cycle
to the for all of our modalities are
tagged with a part of the solution helix
if appropriate and so they can see
really where they are in that in that
system in review we have a chapter
review and we make this we make this
very clear that it's segmented into the
different parts of the of the helix so
we're asking them questions about
definition and what assumptions have you
made in the translation here is kind of
more about how did you abstract this you
know explain explain what you've done
with your frontal area it's what
formulas are you using and then the
computation here is is kind of what
value did your model predict you know
we're checking that they've really kind
of associated these things and then we
also prompt them with critiquing and
interpretation questions as well this
this is a new this is the new part of
the materials from feedback that we've
had from several of our pilots it wasn't
inherently obvious that we're actually
teaching the problem-solving cycle first
and foremost and kind of maths concepts
and contextualization second it wasn't
kind of we wanted to kind of represent
that visually and that's been really
clear and it also helps as a guide so
that when people are thinking about
approaching problems of their own
they have kind of like a four step
markup to do that so I thought I thought
I'd show you a bit of this in action as
they're going through their notebook
they're kind of defining all of their
forces so they're force one is they're
rolling resistance they're forced to is
there air resistance and the force three
takes into account gradient and they're
building up these power models with the
things that they've kind of included in
it obviously I haven't spent an hour
doing that so I I have my model
definition here
but I figured that most of you probably
wouldn't care how fast that we cycle to
around island so I thought we could
cycle for Champaign to Chicago so we've
built this tool here we're very much
about about kind of giving people real
things to use and we have the route here
there's just a normal GPX route we're
using real real data and what this tool
does is it segmented it into different
sections here based on gradient in fact
you're very very lucky in that I don't
think there's like any proper Hills here
so you should be able to do that you
should be able to do that really really
quickly if I said on Google Maps it was
going to take me like between 12 and 13
hours and I figured it'd probably be
quicker to fly but but this is it and
then this is where they can kind of see
what's happening this is the model that
they've done I'm going to paste my
formula in here what if I call my
velocity argument I'm being very very
yeah and what power are you using and
then I'm going to run my model and the
model is then computing given all of the
things that they've put in their
velocity in their time for the different
sections of this now that it complies
for any anything they want we've asked
them to apply it to the to the stage
seven of the outpost or us but they can
apply to anything they like but the the
really important thing here is that they
can see immediately that the effect that
the model that they've trainers have is
having so this says either add a power
output a continued power output which as
the cyclist makes me go weak at the
knees of 120 watts they would have they
would take them ten thousand thirty five
minutes which is about two hours
quicker than Google says it is but if
you if you if you kind of change this
and we can say that I'm going to be
really slow today
then actually it's going to take me
thirteen your house which is probably
probably much more appropriate so this
is something that they can then play
with and we ask them in the following
sections to to really critique this you
know could you could you really cycle
the stage in that time you know the
answer is no they're looking at data
from actual cyclists doing this and
we've exposed them in the previous parts
of the module to we have some videos
from some famous Irish cyclists as well
and some real cycling models and if you
ever seen a cycling model it's it's got
you know five billion different
variables that they can use we've only
taken three effects into account okay
there they are the major effects but we
want to kind of get them to think about
well what's the next stage what could
they do with that and at the end of the
module we've we've got here the project
which is about applying what you've
learnt in this module but but in a
guided way to a completely different
problem so we've got this the problem of
finding a maximum velocity during a
freefall skydive and instead of taking
them through this what we've done is
we've segmented it into the four
different helix areas and we're giving
them probing questions I'm not sure if
you can see this but you know you know
what information do I need what factors
change during a freefall and which are
constant its probing them with questions
what physical relationships or equations
apply to this problem and it's kind of
scaffolding them and then the and then
of course we we give the teachers some
hints as well
these are intersections won't get seen
by the students so and this is all part
of it and this is the part where the
teacher can really engage in what
they're doing and it's and it's a much
more kind of creative approach so that's
basically what we've been doing with
module right now
so where are we going we have some
really exciting pilots and projects on
at the moment we we have we're in a
second pilot phase of our statistics
curriculum which is rolling out in
schools in Estonia the Indian government
have had a statistics curriculum we're
rolling out the second pilot we have
project in Africa at the moment we have
links with Sweden and we also have this
this this collaboration with with the
Irish assessment board as well one of
the key facets of CBM and any kind of
curriculum in general is how do we
assess this and we've been talking to
some major assessment bodies including
national assessment boards in the UK and
and in Europe about kind of what is the
best way to assess CBM and it's a
different it's a different way from
traditional maths it's about having a
kind of more kind of creative marking
process maybe project based assessment
allowing people to kind of assessing
their thinking rather than just their
just their actual output and then
cloud-based CBM were obviously a huge
facet of what we're doing all of our
projects right now have site licenses of
Mathematica we all of our Estonian
materials were deployed on CDF player
but now we've got you know some robust
cloud technology for deployment and for
access we are migrating our materials
over into the Wolfram cloud obviously
everything that you've seen today is
written in Wolfram language that's the
framework that's completely built out of
war now which you don't use anything
else and so we're kind of migrating
things to to the Wolfram cloud and
hoping to build some kind of deployment
mechanism around that so as a pet
project I wanted to show you our new
website and for any of you who haven't
been at the computer based maths website
you won't see a change but anyone who
has seen a computer-based math website
you'll see a significant change and I
just wanted to leave you with the little
animation that's on the top of the page
which which is trying to tell the story
of kind of
how computer-based maths can fix the
current education crisis
this was even but full 3d printing came
in
[Music]
you know if you have any questions just
let me know but thank you very much
[Applause]